it's good to wear sunscreen year round
but it is really the time of year for
sunscreen right now you may have heard
FDA warnings about chemical sunscreens
which can cause skin irritation and
other issues that's why it's best to use
a mineral sunscreen like the one by
Ginger armor it is just as effective
much safer and you'll save 15 percent
with the code Pacman the link is down
below
let's start today with a discussion
about the economy is the economy a
disaster well many on the right say that
it is now we're going to look at the
most important metrics for evaluating
how the economy is doing the reason I'm
doing this is whether you're on the left
or on the right my suggestion is don't
make this political many on the right
who say the Biden economy is a disaster
are making this political and you know
that while I have my political opinions
I don't think we should have a death
penalty I think abortion should be legal
and accessible and affordable in most
cases I believe in the decriminalization
if not legalization of many drugs and
these These are opinions of mine when it
comes to things like gas prices debt and
deficit the economy my preference is to
take an extremely sober empirical
approach and we can always predict a
recession is coming the type of economic
system we have at least historically has
always eventually gotten to a recession
or a depression could we enter into one
tomorrow sure will we probably get into
one at some point yeah probably but when
people come to you maybe with tears in
their eyes and then they say the Biden
economy is a disaster I would challenge
you to say to them which underlying
metric tells us that let's look at the
most important ones GDP growth the last
few quarters 3.2 percent growth 2.6
percent growth 1.3 percent growth
very unremarkable not mind-blowingly
explosive the way we saw during the
immediate coveted recovery
and not problematic right I mean you
zoom out and you see GDP growth has been
in this relatively tight range big
decline for covid big recovery in that
quarter after the big Decline and then
just fine GDP growth numbers so we say
is GDP indicative of an economic problem
no it is not we then go to the
unemployment rate
one of the lowest unemployment rates
we've had the chart on the screen goes
back before 1950 looks like it starts
around 1948 and we see periods where
unemployment has been down in the three
percent range a period in the early 50s
a period in the late 60s touching the
the very high threes around the year
2000 the.com boom
um and then spiking right when covet hit
and we are now down to
3.6 unemployment one of the lowest
unemployment rates in history so we say
well the picture painted by GDP and
unemployment certainly is not indicative
of an economic crisis as of today we
then look at the inflation rate but
David sir everything is so expensive
because of the Biden inflation well if
you actually look that inflationary
period started well before Biden it has
been historically higher than we saw
During the period starting in the mid
90s but but inflation has now declined
declined declined to just below right
around five percent
exactly where I predicted we would be
towards the end of the summer I said
somewhere between four and five percent
it seems like we will be there this is
not hugely shocking if you've been
following the trend line and you see
that while we still have higher
inflation than we've had you have to go
back to you know around 2010 we had a
little bit of a spike in inflation and
then you look at around 1990 and then
certainly in the mid 70s very high
inflation uh World War II era okay
inflation has been higher it's coming
down so now we build the picture GDP
unemployment inflation it doesn't look
like a crisis we then look at the
consumer confidence index now this is an
opinion based index admittedly and you
do see that when we were in the thick of
covid consumer confidence declined
significantly it is important it is
important to look at the y-axis here and
see that it goes from 96 to 102. this is
a relatively tight range it is
absolutely true that right before
the.com bust a consumer confidence was
very high
um and then in the midst of the
2008-2009 recession consumer confidence
was low it got very low during covid and
it is now recovered to a level that we
saw around 2012 and to a level we saw
during the recovery from 2008 and in the
early 90s so consumer confidence has
been low but it is climbing well what
about stock market performance David
let's look at that S P 500
um four percent one-year return not
amazing but certainly not a crisis year
to date 11 return from the S P 500 the
three-year is now a 10
annualized return very very healthy you
look at five year nine percent return
and ten year 10 return the stock market
is basically fine yes we see these
erratic erratic up and down days uh
sporadically that's something that's
been part of the stock market so we're
not finding any red flags well maybe
unemployment is low and GDP is okay in
consumer confidence is increasing and
the stock market is doing fine
but what about wages well we look at the
federal wage growth tracker and you see
that wage growth sustained now starting
about uh a year and a quarter ago
has been at some of the highest levels
that we've seen
dating all the way back to 1980 wage
growth but these are crappy jobs well
wages are going up and you actually see
very nice wage growth so the fine we
have many jobs but they are crap wage
growth seems to be doing okay we then
look at the balance of trade and you see
that we still have a trade deficit but
after bottoming out
um a couple years ago the trade deficit
has been reduced reduced reduced it's
really important to understand if you
look at this chart you'll see that we've
had trade deficits dating all the way
back to the mid 70s we have had trade
deficits in the United States since 1976
because we have become a country
that Imports a ton of oil and consumer
products okay the trade balance is not
particularly
shocking if you understand the American
economy and then lastly well what about
interest rates yes we are seeing an
increase in interest rates this is
making mortgages more expensive this is
also making it so that you can get five
percent in a high yield savings account
which is pretty damn attractive I will
tell you what you have to understand
about interest rates and we have a chart
up on the screen where you see extremely
high interest rates in the early 80s and
then you see extremely low interest
rates almost zero from about two
thousand eight up until about 2016.
interest rates in the U.S reach their
highest level in 1981. and you can see
it on the chart because the FED raised
rates to combat soaring inflation and to
try to stabilize the economy that's the
story of high interest rates in 81.
since then we've seen interest rates
basically decline for 40 years
all the way down to essentially zero
levels in 2010 after the global
financial crisis again in 2020 they
dropped back to zero after the coveted
pandemic and now interest rates are
going back up to a level that we saw in
2006 still below what where we saw right
before 9 11 well below what we had in
the late 80s so there is really no big
dramatic story on interest rates as well
so I continue to recommend when these
economy doom and gloomers come to you
and they start telling you these stories
about the Biden economy the first thing
to say is listen the less regulated the
version of capitalism we have the more
endemic to the system booms and busts
will be
there may well be a recession or
depression coming but what current
indicator is suggestive of that now the
one I didn't mention which they might go
to is labor participation rate the
population of the country continues to
go up and so it is true that at most
times there are more people than ever
working
and more people than ever not working it
is not a particular particularly
reliable indicator of economic health
and that's why I didn't even include it
ask them for the facts show them the
receipts Mike Pence is running for
president one of the most electric and
inspiring candidates no that's not true
that's actually very much untrue uh Mike
Pence this is a weird 2024 Republican
primary already Mike Pence also spoke at
the Iowa roast and ride and it is
actually stunning how Mike Pence is
embroiled in a battle with Ron DeSantis
for who could possibly be the least
charismatic candidate so far here is
pence in his speech no one understood
nor cared about
[Applause]
it is great to be back at the roast and
ride
I rode and I roasted on the ride wow
just absolutely electric delivery as you
can see there
um Pence seemingly out of ideas he's
sort of you know how on gun violence
it's like we've tried nothing and we're
all out of ideas is very often what you
hear from some on the right
um Pence so far has really tried nothing
to justify his candidacy and he's just
doing a little bit of the DeSantis stuff
talking about Bud Light and you know
Target I don't think that this is if
DeSantis can't win with this stuff I
don't know that Pence can win with the
exact same stuff he also has to stand up
for American families okay
you know the truth the matter is we
stand here today yeah the radical left
has been assaulting our values and
assaulting our families almost as never
before well talk to me about how that's
going to get me a better paying job or
more job security Mike oh right it won't
it's the same nonsense DeSantis is
peddling
but the great thing I've seen traveling
across this country is that the American
people
American people are on to it
are they just ask Bud Light
Target
and by the way
a message to Major League Baseball
religious bigotry has no place in
America's pastime you can tell he really
means it because he's moving his hands
[Applause]
all right and Pence pointing to someone
into the crowd and mouthing thank you as
you can see this campaign does not
exactly have Victory written all over it
here is Mike Pence interviewed either
right before or right after this thing
he's wearing some kind of biker vest it
might be leather it might be pleather
and
um asked about his big announcement
which is scheduled for tomorrow and if
anybody was worried that Mike Pence's
announcement might not be blessed by God
he has been praying about it he notifies
us ride 50 miles into the the State
Fairgrounds if that doesn't say I'm
running for president I don't know what
is are you ready to make a decision
well we're looking forward to being back
in Iowa next Wednesday yeah Karen and I
spent a lot of time over the last two
years reflecting and frankly praying
about where we might uh the same God
that told George W bush to go into Iraq
when he prayed is apparently advising
the pences next serve our country after
our years in Congress our years as
governor of Indiana and yours as vice
president and if we've come to a
decision I thought there'd be no better
place to announce our decision than
right here in the Hawkeye State but let
me ask you right super super exciting as
you can see so listen how it
how is Mike what is Mike Pence doing how
is Mike Pence doing in this race the
latest polling has Mike Pence at an
anemic 3.8 percent I'll be honest I
don't even know how Mike Pence has a
path to getting ahead of Ron DeSantis
never mind catching Donald Trump I don't
understand Mike Pence's argument for
even being a candidate if you didn't
like the Trump Administration Pence was
part of that Administration if you did
like the Trump Administration Trump's
running and you can vote for Trump and
if you didn't like Trump but you want
someone with a viable path to Victory
you've got Ron DeSantis if you want a
woman representing the Republican Party
you've got Nikki Haley if you want a
black guy representing the Republican
Party you've got Tim Scott if you want
a guy who's good at debating
representing the Republican Party you've
got Chris Christie I don't know what
path there is for this guy and it makes
me wonder why is he running at all
I haven't heard him justify it in any
way that makes sense maybe somebody in
the audience has a clue let me know make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the David
Pacman show that's a forward slash folks
don't go in with those backslashes don't
don't you dare
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
my friends once arrested and twice
impeached failed former president Donald
Trump is about to get arrested again and
this time it appears federal charges are
coming Trump's lawyers meeting with the
justice department yesterday reportedly
begging them please please with tears in
their eyes don't charge Donald Trump CBS
news reports Trump attorneys meet with
special counsel at justice department
amid documents investigation great
report by Robert Costa and others
attorneys representing Trump met with
special counsel Jack Smith and
prosecutors at the justice department 10
a.m yesterday according to two people
familiar with the matter this took place
weeks after Trump's lawyers requested a
meeting with top federal law enforcement
officials the attorneys for Trump spent
just under two hours inside the main
Justice building and declined to comment
as they left
CBS News cameras captured Trump's legal
team walking in the former president's
lawyers did not speak as they entered a
person familiar with the meeting between
the three attorneys and the department
said Merrick Garland was not there two
people familiar with the probe say
Trump's legal team is frustrated with
how the justice department has handled
attorney-client matters in recent months
and would likely raise concerns during
the meeting in particular prosecutors
discussions of related issues in front
of the grand jury
um additional reporting from The
Washington Post Trump lawyers ask
justice department not to charge Trump
in the classified documents case we now
have reporting here about the reason for
the visit quote attorneys for Donald
Trump went to the justice department
Monday to make their case the government
should not charge the former president
in connection with his possession of
classified documents after leaving
office as reported already in the other
article they were there for two hours
Merit Garland wasn't there justice
department has not commented this is an
interesting paragraph while it is not
uncommon in high profile cases for
defense lawyers to get such a meeting
with Justice Department officials
towards the end of an investigation
current and former officials say such
presentations rarely change prosecutors
Minds two Trump advisors briefed on
Monday's meetings say they continue to
believe Smith will file analyze a
charging decision in coming weeks the
advisors say they are preparing for a
potential indictment of the former
president the meeting did not change
their expectations Donald Trump by all
reasonable reports is about to get
arrested again indicted again this time
on federal charges these aren't even the
only federal charges Trump might be
charged for remember that there is a
federal investigation into Trump's
mishandling of classified documents
which we now know took place not only at
Mar-A-Lago but also at Bedminster we now
know Trump knew they were classified
based on an audio recording of trump
saying I have a document here but I
can't show it to you because it's
classified which confirms Trump knew he
had not actually Declassified the
documents that's one slate of federal
charges that could be coming
in addition there are the potential
charges referred to the justice
department by the former house committee
investigating the insurrectionist Trump
Riots of January 6 2021 that could lead
to charges and in addition to that
Fannie Willis in Georgia will be making
a charging decision on state level
charges against Trump sometime between
July and September when the next grand
jury is reconvened and those decisions
are going to be made we could see one
two or even three additional arrests of
the once arrested twice impeached former
president just over the summer the
question we are all now asking is
whether this will impact Trump's
campaign for the Republican candidacy
and who of the other people running for
the Republican candidacy or the
Republican nomination stand to benefit
the most it seems It's DeSantis because
he's the only one in double digits at
this point in terms of the polling but
we'll look at that a little more deeply
probably Thursday if not Friday in the
meantime Trump's reaction to news that
he will likely be arrested completely
and totally unhinged it appears as
though Donald Trump was notified by his
lawyers yesterday after their meeting
with the justice department that he will
almost certainly be getting arrested and
charged federally Donald Trump
immediately took to his social media
platform truth social truth essential
where he ranted about how other
presidents Obama haven't been arrested
or indicted I guess for the crimes Trump
may have committed you've got to see
this mostly with caps lock engaged
Donald Trump posting after his lawyers
gave him the bad news quote how can doj
possibly charge me who did nothing wrong
when no other presidents were charged
there's an apostrophe on presidents we
don't know why it's a it that's a
totally woke apostrophe we're not going
to do the woke grammar in Florida where
if you do the apostrophe when you
actually don't mean possessive you mean
plural we're just not gonna do it
teachers won't be allowed will will fire
him right away okay when no other
presidents were charged when Joe Biden
won't be charged for anything including
the fact that he has 850 boxes much of
it classified and some dating back to
his Senate day when even Democrat
senators are shocked also President
Clinton had documents in one Court
crooked Hillary deleted 33 000 emails
many classified and wasn't even close to
being charged only Trump the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time
so
Trump Furious that other presidents
haven't been charged
for the crimes Trump committed okay this
morning getting even more Bonkers on
truth trothing out a lot of agit trash
including quote the marxists and
fascists in the doj and FBI are going
after me at a level and speed never seen
before in our Capital C country and I
did nothing wrong first question can we
identify a single FBI Marxist after
years of talking about it do we know of
a single Marxist in the doj Trump
continuing Joe Biden kept keeps
thousands of documents in many locations
some illegally taken from Skiffs while
he was a Senator a big portion of which
were classified he didn't want to give
them back and still doesn't nothing
happens to him with same reasonable
prosecutor who correctly exonerated Mike
Pence I have a much different prosecutor
a trump hater then Trump going in the
direction of saying it's all about
impacting Trump's 24 run saying quote
it's all about election interference
they don't want to run against me I ran
twice I did much better the second time
getting millions and millions more votes
than the first a record for a sitting
president and them leading Biden in the
polls by a lot they are the capital P
party of capital D disinformation they
are using the doj and FBI against me to
capital r double G rig that's a doozy
capital r double G rig the 2024 election
they'll hit Hunter with something small
to make their strike on me look Fair
nothing about these capital F fascists
is fair or honest fight these things are
almost impossible to read and then
lastly
as of an hour ago although he probably
has posted more quote they are also
going after me as retribution for the
republicans in Congress going after them
the difference is they have created
Major Crimes I have created none now for
many of you wondering did we get to the
bottom of Obama gate the biggest
political crime of the century As Trump
once said no we still don't know what
Obama gate is and so the questions about
why Clinton or Obama or hunter or
whoever haven't been charged it appears
as though at this time
there is not evidence of criminality
period that would be the reason Trump
melting down on Troth Central we can
only hope that Justice is done
did people hear that notice how I'm not
saying I hope Trump is thrown in prison
and they throw away the key blah blah
blah what I'm saying is I hope that if
the evidence points to criminality
Justice is done
that's called Law and Order
okay not lock this person up despite no
evidence of criminality not lock that
person up or kill people
execute people even absent to guilty
verdict no it is I hope that there if
there is evidence nobody is above the
law all of these posts from truth will
be on our Instagram they will be on Tick
Tock and they will certainly be on
Facebook that I promise you
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today Dylan Burns Dylan is a
streamer and an aspiring War journalist
currently with an emphasis on Ukraine he
joins us from Ukraine now uh so Dylan
how long have you been in Ukraine off
and on now
uh in total about a year now I came over
first uh in late April of last year I
spent uh most of that year we're at
least half of that year over in Ukraine
before heading back over for the
holidays to spend time with family and
I've been over here again since March to
film with the mining Crews interview
soldiers who have fought in Bach Moot
and uh in bed with people on the front
line uh who have been delivering Aid to
civilians in need so one of the claims
that different folks are making uh uh is
that the death toll in Ukraine is not
being accurately represented I mean
there's people on the political left
that have said this Donald Trump has
said this do you have any insight into
that I guess just generally
so a lot of the estimates that people go
off of are the official un estimates and
I'm going to be honest I've only seen
the UN once since I've been here on the
ground the UN are not very visible when
it comes to Frontline communities in the
areas that are most seen death and
destruction and the UN also does not
have access to a lot of communities that
have seen the worst of the violence this
war has brought to Ukraine they don't
have rental ready and available access
to locations like a mariopal or uh for
example Bachman cities that have seen
high amounts of Civilian casualties
maryopal especially and the Russians
have done a lot of work to cover up
their tracks people saw as they
evacuated Kiev how the soldiers were
trying to burn bodies in order to cover
up exactly what happened in the torture
and the summary executions that were
going on in their quote unquote
cleansing operation that's the word they
used in private Communications to
describe what they were doing in the key
of old blast not the word I used so I do
think that the uh death toll is horribly
underestimated by how much I don't know
but most estimates that I've seen that
are more serious seems to have the
civilian death toll
um much much higher than the 8 to 10 to
15 000 that the U.N is estimating at
this point we're talking more in the um
like hundreds of thousands um or at
least over a hundred thousand okay so
that's that's dramatically different and
dramatically more tragic
um the demons the information vary of
course of course of course the demining
talk a little bit about what this is
what are these minds and where what what
are the origins of those minds and what
is the demining operation
so recently I spent a month embedded
with d minors in the heart of oblast and
operating liberated territory mostly I
was with them as they tried to remove
mines that were you know anti-personnel
mines uh um pmf ones which are butterfly
mines which the Soviets use heavily in
Afghanistan uh anti-tank mines the pmf
ones are are notorious in the way that
they don't really look like a normal
mind they actually look kind of like a
toy and so in Afghanistan Afghan
children used to be known to pick them
up thinking they were a toy before
losing their entire arm losing their leg
and they are scattered over a lot of
Civilian areas in this war and they have
been scattered uh both um in Russian
occupied territory and you and you in
territory that's controlled by the
Ukrainian government and in the time
that I spent with those D minors in the
ark of oblast
um not only the deminers in our area die
but also civilians died in our area from
these mines and it was only around one
specific small City in the heart of loss
and this is happening all over
territories that were occupied by the
Russians anywhere that is liberated has
to be meticulously cleared by D minors
afterwards but the amount of explosives
that we're working with we're talking
about 70 to 100 years of demining work
post-war the 70-year estimate by the way
I was told four months ago if the war
stopped immediately wow so it's probably
worse than uh current estimates once
this is all over it'll probably be much
worse
currently being laid are they are they
more in rural areas where they can be
hidden or in what sorts of places are
they
they're in all types of locations
they're in a lot of farms and farm
Fields right they place a lot of
anti-tank mines there because they were
the Russians were scared that there
would be a counter-offensive that could
punch through those fields there's a lot
of anti-personnel Minds in the force
that I've been in
um again I was filming near power lines
that needed to be restored so they could
bring power to local communities and I
saw mon 50 mines which are basically
like American Claymores I saw pmf ones
and densely populated communities and as
we were driving by
um with these D minors through these
Villages and doing work many many on
many occasions civilians would run up to
the demining crews and uh almost beg
them to come to their homes and remove
the mines that are literally in their
backyard and we're talking
anti-personnel anti-tank many of which
are booby trapped so civilians and D
minors may have a much harder time
removing them what is the process for
removing such a mind of removing
um it depends on the mind if if it's um
an anti-personnel mine like a mon 50 I
did record
um uh much of the process and actually
uploaded it on Twitter if people wanted
to go check it out
um uh usually you have to
um for example I'm on 50 every mine's
different you have to identify where the
tripwire is you need to cut the tripwire
before going to the Detonator and
removing the Detonator but the problem
is That's supposed to be the official
process that's how you're supposed to do
it but many of these minds are booby
trapped so that when you go through this
official process if you don't notice the
other tripwires or the other mines that
are attached to it it can go off and
kill the demanding crew when I was in
the heart of Hope Loss we actually lost
some sesu workers emergency service
workers to anti-tank mines that were
booby trapped there was one anti-tank
bind but under it there were four other
anti-tank mines creating an incredible
explosion that killed some of our guys
over there what's what's the radius at
which these these things are dangerous
it depends on the mind if we're talking
like a butterfly mine it's only going to
be like maybe like 10 15 feet but if
we're talking anti-tank mines it's going
to be much greater distance which can
injure and maim and kill a lot more
people and how many minds are put
together right because if again it was
five anti-tank mines so that can kill a
lot of people
there are social media videos that are
released and I don't know what point
people are trying to make with some of
these videos but I've just seen the
videos and the videos are of almost like
idyllic coffee shop scenes in different
parts of Ukraine and I don't know if the
argument that's trying to be made is
lots of people are ignoring what's going
on and just going about their lives or
certain parts of the country are
completely safe and this is only
affecting part of the country can you
talk a little bit about whether this
dichotomy does exist and whether there
are Parts where it is just business as
usual hipster coffee shops and flat
whites
sure so most of these videos originate
in Kiev I've seen a lot of them where
it's like oh here is like a coffee shop
in Kiev or Club in Kiev yeah and if you
would compare what it's like to being
kiev for example Bachman obviously the
living standard is going to be much
different it's not on directly to front
line they cannot be shelled directly by
Russian Artillery which was a major
contributor to a lot of Youth civilian
casualties in harkiv when the Russian
Artillery guns were in front of harkiv
they constantly shelved the city in my
opinion I think it was a deliberate Act
of Revenge due to the fact that they
couldn't take the city and they took a
lot of casualties trying to take the
city
um and so when those artillery guns are
pushed back that does save a lot of
Civilian lives but most if not all of
Ukraine is in range of Russian cruise
missiles
um the S 300 missiles that they kind of
retrofit to be used that's just like
rockets to like lob them at the city
they're not terribly accurate but the
point isn't to be accurate the point is
to whittle down Ukraine's air defense
the point and in my opinion is the
terrorizes civilian population and even
though I'm in the supposedly trampled
key of in fact I'm even in a more
tranquil part of Kiev because I'm not in
the city itself I'm in the countryside
but um last week live on stream a
missile passed a few hundred feet over
our home and it was caught on stream I
had to end stream because of it so every
part in of Ukraine could be
hypothetically bombed by the Russians at
any time and that's why I think air
defense is so important to protect
civilian lives and I can tell you since
the Patriot air defense has been here in
the key of oblast it has been busy can
you talk about you you had a situation
where a Russian drone spotted you can
you talk about that
sure
um during my last trip while I was here
my first front line in bed I was going
to hang out with the zaparosa
territorial defense as they went to the
Ford operating position that means the
last position until the Russians it was
about one to maybe one and a half mile
from the Russians the Ford operating
position we were going to
um I was going there in what was the
equivalent of a soccer mom van painted
green that was constantly breaking down
but
um that's of course due to the fact that
the territorial defense their local
Defenders and they don't have a lot of
times the best equipment as much as you
always see like the tanks and everything
in the foreign media much of that
equipment has still yet to arrive in
Ukraine and much of that equipment um is
is being used by uh is being stored in
there and they're waiting to use it in
the counter offensive and so not
everybody has the best equipment and the
situation has improved since since I've
been with them and I did this as well
but on the way to the front line
um we were told that the position was
getting shelled so we had to get out of
the van and we just kind of hanged out
on the side of the road and then I heard
this just like weird buzzing sound like
30 minutes and just just kind of waiting
on the side of the road like your phone
vibrates or maybe like a small swarm of
bees and I look to my friend and
colleague Patrick hillsman and I asked
him like what do you hear that and he
says I don't hear it I'm like okay
whatever then five seconds later
somebody else drone we all have to run
into the forest hide there for like
three to four minutes nobody knows if
it's a suicide drone nobody knows if it
has like a grenade attached to it which
is going to drop on us we or if it's a
spotter drone that's spotting Ford
Hillary right so then the decision is
made that we have to run for it we run
into the soccer mom van get in drive a
few miles uh away before parking back
into the forest to try to rethink a plan
on where to go next
um after 15 minutes my friend Patrick
hillsman is adamant that the artillery
we heard in the distance was our former
position getting shelled well I never
confirmed it but he's adamant that
that's what he uh that's what happened
uh once we were we decided that you know
it's too dangerous to be in the this
area we'd get into the soccer mom van
again they try to start it it breaks
down so we're there for another five
minutes just hoping to get the soccer
mom van you know back and running again
we jump in it finally you know gets
running and we go off to SPG nine
practice
um I'm happy the soccer mom van started
yeah to say the least
um Dylan have you needed medical
attention I don't mean from injuries
sustained while doing this stuff but I
just mean like you've been there a year
have you needed to Avail yourself of any
kind of doctors or the medical system
there and if so what was that like
no I've I've thankfully I've never had
to get medical attention there's been a
few times where we've been uh near
somebody when they got hurt and we had
to apply first aid to them
um when we were in the Don bass
specifically uh chromatous which is a
major location the Russians have been
bombing and trying to capture we were
with an elderly woman at a dog shelter I
think actually the only functioning dog
shelter in uh the city which has since
been bombed since we were there
um there was somebody who needed medical
attention but I have never needed it the
closest I've needed it is when watching
like Tucker talk about it you know like
maybe in an aspirin or something okay
got it
um what's the plan for how long to stay
there and and when to come home
so I don't know exactly for me I kind of
I want to keep filming until I feel like
I've I've gotten enough
um I know I want to be home for
Christmas but I'm probably going to be
here again next year as well I want to
keep covering this war until all major
hostilities have ceased uh I think that
it deserves the coverage there is a
million different stories to tell and I
want to make sure that people can't lie
about the type of disgusting that's
going on here
wow uh Dylan Burns in Ukraine streaming
oh by the way the streams are they at 6
PM Eastern but you're there so like are
you streaming in the middle of the night
Ukraine time is that what's going on I'm
streaming I'm streaming from 1am to late
late streams and why that's
I I want to concentrate on making sure
that this message gets to an American
audience because
as much as I do have Ukrainian viewers
and my Ukrainian audience has certainly
grown since I've been covering here yeah
um the main I don't need to tell
ukrainians that their country uh is
being torn apart I don't need to tell
you ukrainians or explain to them the
importance of air defense they
understand it they understand it more
better than anybody else in the world
sure if there's any audience that needs
this message it's the American public
who are constantly being lied to uh
about either the oh the war is not as
serious as they say or the war crimes
aren't as bad as it is or oh you know
it's not really that important or uh you
know or for example Tucker Carlson line
about the seven to one numbers for every
one Ukrainian uh for everyone Russian
that died seven ukrainians uh in the
military died these this that's the
audience I want to aim at because that's
the audience that is being lied to
because uh the Russians want to undercut
American support in America for for
Ukraine so they can trample across the
country loot pillage and Conquer it
Dylan really appreciate the work you're
doing and stay stay safe and let's talk
again
thank you very much you have a fantastic
day
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so Fox
News host Jesse Waters has really
outdone even the low standards he set
for himself with a new baseless
conspiracy theory and just wild
allegation against Joe Biden in his
latest unhinged rant on Fox News Waters
is now claiming that the FBI installed
Joe Biden as president as a quote
intelligence operation after
blackmailing Biden for a decade with a
fabric I guess with a fabricated
allegation of bribery now this is this
is crazy for a fox host to say you know
we see this stuff on other platforms
real America's voice Newsmax those types
of places we sometimes see this level of
unhinged and baseless conspiracy theory
on Fox News presented by a guest and the
the host will usually kind of play a
objective reporter but from a fox Host
this is actually pretty wacky stuff so
let's take a listen to this and where
this why Jesse Waters is doing this
where it's surface I don't know maybe
it's
um a response to some kind of hunger
from the Fox News audience for some new
red meat conspiracy about Joe Biden I
don't know but let's listen to it now
once you cover politics for a while you
realize the presidents aren't the
powerful ones it's the people who put
the presidents in the White House
they're the powerful ones ah that we've
always known politicians or puppets Joe
Biden confessed it to a group of kids
I heard you had to get back to the Oval
Office and by the way the one thing I
thought when I got to be president
I get to give orders but I take more
orders than I ever did and you're right
by the way like as if that's a Smoking
Gun
that to me it's just as easily could
mean I work for the people who voted for
me right I take orders from the voters
which sounds to me very much like
something Biden would say or simply
joking about the number of Demands and
people that make demands of a president
like the idea of that is a Smoking Gun
for this wild conspiracy is laughable
but let's continue
so that he can take orders not give them
groom does
and now that he's literally slept his
weight at the top they won't let him go
anywhere what the FBI put their guy in
the White House you think we're just
gonna like let voters decide if you
should serve four more years we can't
afford to take that risk
Joe Biden's been an intelligence Ops
since he was vice president one of the
FBI's top informants a guy with
impeccable credentials a great track
record reported an allegation that Joe
Biden took a five million dollar bribe
right under Barack Obama's nose from a
foreign National in exchange for a
policy decision that is not true they've
been blackmailing well you know I think
I should be more accurate there's no
evidence at this time that that's true
you know it's sort of like when people
say oh hydroxychloroquine
it's not at initially at least it wasn't
it doesn't work for covid it's right now
there's no evidence it doesn't work for
covet maybe in the future there will be
such evidence there wasn't by the way
Biden with this for a decade well until
a whistleblower came forward and now
James Comer wants a document released to
Congress and the FBI is caught in a
cover-up yeah the the That's The
Whistleblower we can't find we don't
know where the where where the
Whistleblower is this this is
particularly absurd and irresponsible
now I know many of you are probably
saying David you know they do those
circus Revival things on the weekends
and they say stuff like this all the
time you go on to these Conspiracy
YouTube channels and they say stuff like
this on the time they do this is Fox
News and this is a different level of
crazy it's a different level of
irresponsible it's also dangerous and
Incredibly divisive because underlying
this if I give you the conspiracy theory
that the Earth is flat okay I'm not
undermining the legitimacy of our
democracy you you could say well if you
think it should be taught in school
just saying I think the Earth is flat or
you know there were two people involved
in the killing of JFK instead of one or
some it's not directly undermining
our democracy and how presidents are
elected in the rule of law but when you
say the FBI put Biden in as an
intelligence operation it had nothing to
do with the way people voted your fuel
fueling paranoia and anger and we know
that Trump supporters already had enough
paranoia and anger to do what they did
on January 6th based on being unable or
unwilling to accept the reality of the
defeat of Donald Trump they also
distract from real issues like whatever
right I mean quite literally any issue
would be more important than the the
conspiracy theory that the FBI uh
operated uh did an operation in which
they put Biden in the White House and
and really it wasn't Biden who won it
might have been Trump but it didn't
matter because the FBI set it all up
could be climate change could be the
economy it could be anything quite
literally anything would be more
important than this and of course if you
say does Waters have evidence to back
this up he doesn't what he's referring
to is the same Anonymous sources that
Trump and others regularly attack and
say we should and be listening to
dubious documents that don't even say
the things they claim they say maybe his
imagination maybe his desire for
something like this to be true or his
desire for Ratings or I don't know and
of course nowhere in there is the fact
that the numbers with which Joe Biden
won you know more than seven million
votes obviously at the Electoral level
it depended on a far smaller number of
votes just like Trump's Victory depended
in 2016 an election which at each
individual state was certified and
despite more than 60 cases and the other
thing you would think that in that
investigation the auditing and the
forensics and looking for barbecue sauce
on ballots and fibers and all these
different things
if this was actually an FBI op there
would be some evidence of that there
would be and in fact there is not so I
don't have to tell you that Waters is
not a journalist he actually you know
I'm super clear on my show I'm not a
journalist I do commentary opinion and
Analysis this here I'm not doing
original reporting we look at reporting
and we discuss it we analyze and I give
my opinion that's what this is take it
or leave it okay I'm not doing what your
local news reporter does on Fox news
they deliberately blur these lines and
even though Waters sort of presents
himself like he's reporting news to you
he's not a journalist and he's not a
reporter he's a propagandist and he
regularly tells lies promulgates
disinformation all in service of the
right-wing agenda that Fox News has made
their money on he's not interested in
truth he's not interested in facts he's
interested in ratings and creating fear
and scapegoating which is the way that
Fox News Works to serve their pockets
not to serve the public interest and
maybe to serve his ego as well I would
probably say that's a factor too
I want to look at one more clip of Nikki
Haley's recent CNN Town Hall I already
played for you yesterday on the Monday
show a clip of Nikki Haley who's running
for president in on for the Republican
nomination for president Dead on Arrival
has no shot maybe running for vice
president more than she's running for
president I already played a clip for
you of Nikki Haley sort of going
anti-trans I have another clip I want to
look at in more detail because it's so
dishonest and Incorrect and dangerous
and harmful as The Daily Beast reports
Nikki Haley blamed teen suicides on
trans kids in locker rooms trans kids in
locker rooms and this all came during
the segment about how do you define woke
I'm going to play this clip for you and
see if you can find anything that's true
here
take a listen you want to start with
biological boys playing in girls sports
that's one thing the fact that we have
gender pronoun classes in the military
now I mean all of these things that are
pushing what a small minority want on
the majority of Americans it's too much
it's too much I mean the idea that we
have biological boys playing in girls
Sports it is the women's issue of our
time what my daughter ran track in high
school I don't even know how I would
have that conversation with her how are
we supposed to get our girls used to the
fact that biological boys are in their
locker rooms what and then we wonder why
a third of our teenage girls seriously
contemplated suicide last year we should
be growing strong girls confident guys
we shouldn't be surprised about the
level of suicidal ideation and attempts
among teen girls when we see biological
boys in the locker rooms now it's hard
to find a more dishonest Incorrect and
harmful thing to be said now before we
even delve into the suicidal ideation
component of this someone wrote to me
the other day with a really good point
and this isn't this isn't about
stereotyping trans people this is just
sort of like a reality
there are very few trans people first
and foremost
and then you say okay when we go further
how many trans youth are there
playing sports obviously there are but
it is a very small percentage of trans
youth which is a very small percentage
of trans people which is a very small
percentage of the population it doesn't
mean this doesn't exist it doesn't mean
we don't need to deal with it with
empathy and empiricism and all of the
things I advocate for but the idea that
this is the issue of our time is just
laughable now let's go on to the the
data there is no evidence that trans
girls in locker rooms or in sports in
general is causing suicidal ideation in
teenage girls there is no evidence of
that in fact studies show that LGBT
students have higher rates of reported
suicide attempts themselves compared to
heterosexual and cisgendered students
okay so it's it's the opposite of what
Nikki Haley is saying the real causes of
teen Sue suicide and suicidal ideation
seem to be a combination of
gun violence
um concerns about the world lack of
connection in many ways you know
violence hate bullying and yes
unrestricted what Cal Newport calls
unrestricted access to social media
seems to be really really damaging to
teens in general and to teen girls in
particular and so this is a real issue
suicide amongst teens is a real issue
Nikki Haley is using a transphobic Trope
to appeal to a conservative base to
undermine the Dignity of trans people
ignoring the scientific consensus
ignoring reality in ignoring a lot of
the Empirical research we have on this
issue so she should be ashamed of
herself she's overtly spreading
falsehoods out of desperation to get
attention and it's all because her
campaign is failing and failing very
quickly I think it's important to
understand here that if Nikki Haley's
campaign was doing really well my guess
is she wouldn't all of a sudden be
focusing on woken on trans if we look at
the latest data Nikki Haley's polling
4.4 zero path even to catching up to
DeSantis never mind to actually
um uh catching up to Donald Trump so
that's what the this is all about it is
a desperate and very very troubling
search for relevance and meanwhile we
continue receiving more and more data
that anti-woke may be a really silly
tactic for these Republican elected
officials we've been covering the
anti-woke movement being in shambles and
we have another data point in this that
I want to show you right now a new
Gallup study
finds that same-sex marriage support is
at an all-time high 71 percent in the
United States the highlights here are
this figure matches the highest recorded
one in history which was last year
support is lowest among Republicans and
weekly churchgoers if you're a
republican only a 49 chance you support
gay marriage if you go to church weekly
only a 41 young adults and Democrats are
the group's most supportive of gay
marriage if you look at the Historical
chart this goes back to 1996. you see
that in 1996 there was 27 support for
gay marriage another one in other words
the belief that same-sex couples should
be recognized under the law just like
opposite sex couples that has climbed
and climbed and climbed all the way up
to 71
71 if you look at different groups you
find that in terms of church attendance
the more you go to church the less
likely you are to support gay marriage
women slightly more than men support gay
marriage but the numbers are very very
very close and then basically from 50
years of age and up you're less likely
to support gay marriage the group most
likely to support gay marriage is those
18 to 29. if you went to college you're
more likely to support gay marriage than
if you didn't obviously Democrats more
likely than Independents and Republicans
to support it regionally we see that the
South has the lowest support for gay
marriage so what does this tell us this
tells us tells us a number of different
things number one it tells us that the
so-called culture war that the right
loves to say they're prevailing in when
it comes to so-called boys and girls
Sports and woke ideology and drag and
all of these things
the right is losing
you can't find any empirical data that
the right is winning you ask about
abortion support for abortion being
legal in most situations is higher than
ever during the Roe v Wade era today
support for gay marriage higher than
ever you ask people do you think we've
done enough not enough or the right
amount when it comes to
um making trans people feel welcome in
society
the majority says we have either done
the right amount or not enough that's
the and that's not the anti-woke
position I hate to break it to these
folks so that's why the right is trying
to steal elections rather than win them
they will likely ramp up their fascistic
rhetoric and it is in the data you need
only look at all of this data we have to
understand why for DeSantis and Nikki
Haley and Pence now seems to be doing it
the anti-woke agenda is not going to win
them the presidency that's for sure they
need to First figure out how to defeat
Donald Trump I am very interested to see
more as a curiosity than anything else
whether Chris Christie once he enters
the race runs on anti-woke my instinct
is that he will not but remains to be
seen and we're going to watch it very
closely we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P our friend the
Eggman called in the Eggman as you may
know is a Jewish gentleman from a rural
New York State he is reporting an
anti-semitic incident as he was
considering buying a used car
let's listen to the Eggman story
hi Dave I test drove a car that I was
going to buy with a private seller
during the test drive the guy made
anti-submitted comments and and
anti-lgbtq
comments really disgusting when we
finished the test drive I told him in
the Wegmans parking lot to its face the
things he said were vile and disgusting
and I would never buy a car from him he
just stared at me said nothing I drove
away he pulled up next to me the traffic
light spit in my face in the window
cursed me out anti-semitic stuff
anti-lgbtq yelled to me a bunch of spit
in my window I kind of chased him down
but the dude was very scared he drove
over curved evaded me that was
definitely a hate crime right Dave
should I call the police and report it I
do have his actual name from Facebook
Marketplace or should I just blow it off
because that's how things are in Western
New York
Shalom well Shalom to the Eggman so
here's my thought on this I am not a
lawyer nor a police officer the ic2
possible crimes here
it's bidding I guess through that was
one hell of a loogie spitting through
out his window and into the eggman's
window
that's that's a lot but that seems like
that would be a crime and then I don't
know if this is the guy driving over the
curb in an erratic attempt to get away
from the Eggman that maybe is a crime I
don't know if the Eggman was chasing
this guy in his car it's possible the
Eggman committed some crime I don't I
don't know about that so listen I'm
Gonna Leave This one to the audience
should the Eggman report this to the
police and let them handle it or not I
want to hear from you leave a comment on
YouTube maybe make a post on the
subreddit people can have a discussion
that is a hell of a situation hell of a
situation I've been in a lot of
anti-Semitic situations but uh none none
quite like that but glad that the Eggman
is safe on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad Cornell West has
announced that he is running for
president under the People's Party
umbrella a party that is not on the
ballot they have no ballot it access in
any state will be very interesting
discussion on the bonus show I'm sure
YouTube has altered its policy to allow
false claims about past U.S presidential
elections what does this mean and do
they really mean it and lastly Robert
Hansen arguably the most damaging FBI
spy in history has been found dead in
his prison cell I know quite a bit about
Robert Hansen we actually interviewed on
this program uh the FBI agent who was
tasked with catching Robert Hansen
played by Ryan Phillippe eventually in
the movie adaptation of that story a
very interesting situation an incredible
story and we will discuss it on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
it's very cheap folks and it's our
number one source of funding I hope to
see you on the bonus show in a few
minutes
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's good to wear
sunscreen year round but it is really
the time of year for sunscreen right now
you may have heard FDA warnings about
chemical sunscreens which can cause skin
irritation and other issues that's why
it's best to use a mineral sunscreen
like the one by Ginger armor it is just
as effective much safer and you'll save
15 percent with the code Pacman the link
is down below